remember when you had a party
and you couldn't clean up the next day
and you heard the doors of your parents
car shut there was a moment of sheer
terror followed by a moment of almost
immediate acceptance
we're caught we're done
then you just started worrying about
what was it going to be a grounding
who knows maybe they had fun on their
trip maybe they'd be lenient
but after that moment of sheer terror
you were like
you looked around at the house and you
knew it was so bad
that it wasn't one or two things you
could grab there was so much [ __ ]
there they knew what was happening
they're they're gonna get you
and you just had to kind of release
yourself and go hey man
sorry we had a party that's what you
have to tell your children
we had a party for 50 years we did it on
cheap credit uh
we did it by going all around all over
the world and uh doing things we should
not have been doing
bad bad things we had a 50-year party we
bought
homes and cars and we mortgaged them and
we put them on credit cards and
we took out lines of credit we took out
big mortgages we built big
beautiful cities and then stopped giving
a [ __ ] about them and
we we financed this uh with uh
expansion uh you know uh that was
you know financed by war and deceit and
fraud and then we also you know
did this on the backs of of immigrants
that we pay slave labor to
and we did a lot of bad things and there
were good things that came with that
sure but we've had a party
we had a big party and the party was fun
and the music at the party was fun and
well now the music's not too fun at the
party anymore because everybody nobody
can sing anymore
you turn on the music and everybody's
like
help me help me and you go this isn't
this isn't that
fun anymore and you used to be able to
turn on the tv at the party and see some
fun stuff and chuckling
but you can because you turn on the tv
and it chelsea handling like
you're white yeah so that's not fun
anymore either
and the party itself is starting to feel
not too
fun anymore but then there are people at
the party that are going
we can keep the party going if you come
into this
room and you go what's in this room and
you go well there's a million words you
can't say
and you can't look at each other and you
can't have any feelings thoughts or
expressions
and here's a little chip and we're
putting it in your ass and do you have
coronavirus and put on your mask
and don't speak and if you have a
business you can't run it stand in the
corner and look at the [ __ ] floor
and then and there's other people that
are going well we can keep the party
going too but you got to come in this
room and what and i go what do you do in
this room
we just jump around without the music
and we can if you say there is no music
we kill you
we just say the party's going and it's
fun and then you go well if i point out
that the food sucks and there's no music
then we say no dummy did you read q
there isn't supposed to be music at this
party
music's the devil and you go what what
about food
you don't need any [ __ ] food q
provides you all the nutrition you need
you go
so i have a choice between one or two of
these rooms
or you could just sit in the living room
and wait for the parents
and you know who the parents are gonna
be president z
and china and when they open that
[ __ ] door
and they say we're here you're gonna say
mommy and daddy i love you
i'm so [ __ ] sorry i could have got
went in one of these rooms with the
crazy people
but i decided to sit here and stay
here and wait for you i'm so sorry the
kids from school brought people i didn't
know
and they started drinking and smoking
and throwing lamps
and they started buying houses and cars
and going to war
with other houses and i didn't consent
to any of that i just listened to music
i was just trying to get my dick sucked
in the closet i'm trans by the way
and then mommy and daddy we didn't know
we didn't know and then mommy and daddy
are gonna say something in chinese and
then they're gonna zap you and you're
gonna fall to the floor
and they're gonna give you a social
credit score and you're gonna say well
it is what it is folks because the
party's
[ __ ] over